violent chaos unfolds across the
shoreline huge fleshy tendrils Slither
out of the water grabbing people who try
to flee and drag them into the depths as
giant harpoons made of bone whiz across
the beach cutting down unfortunate
sunbathers and troves it is a terrifying
Massacre but you'd never in a million
years be able to guess its source on
April 10th 2010 something strange began
to happen in the three Portlands now the
anomalous extra-dimensional city-state
that overlaps with the locations of
Portland Oregon Portland Maine and the
Isle of Portland is no stranger to
unusual occurrences so it took the
population a little while to notice that
something was happening but for some
unknown reason sailboats and motorboats
were beginning to vanish from the city
the disappearances occurred overnight
when there was no one around to witness
them but slowly the citizens began to
notice that their friends and family
members were going going out in their
watercrafts and never returning home by
April 15th the civilians were becoming
noticeably concerned fearing the worst
on April 16th their worst fears were
confirmed when two local coasts on
karachnid and Greg Moore went for a
nighttime stroll along the harbor they
heard a sudden commotion and rushed to
the scene of the disturbance they
arrived just in time to see a living
individual being dragged into the watery
depths by a large vein-like tendril
Ahmed asked Greg to wait on land while
he ventured out into the water to look
for the victim unfortunately Ahmed never
came back and Greg took his story to the
three Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local
man-eating clam populace to migrate the
FBI unusual incidence unit mounted a
formal investigation on the morning of
April 17th all the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been preying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11 19 a.m 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing veiny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boat
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert izat
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach izat a city security Gollum
in a interfered sadly though the gollum
put up a valiant fight the anomaly was
able to destroy it by Falling onto it
again and again until the gollum was no
longer able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Golem
was not one of them with the Golem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the gruel was in the middle of
a busy brunch service at the site of the
invading watercraft the gruel set down
his picture of bottomless mimosas wiped
his hands on his apron and grabbed his
trusty dual-wheeled swords from
underneath the counter he kept them
there in case someone attempted to dine
and dash but he figured they would do
just fine against a blood-drinking
tugboat while the gruel kept the tugboat
busy uiu forces were able to break
through the barricade of boats for a
brief period of time allowing Morse
security Golems to enter the area as
well as allowing more citizens to escape
unfortunately this little victory was
short-lived as further unforeseen
Horrors dredged themselves up from the
deep the reanimated corpses of various
species native to the harbor began to
crawl out of the water surrounding the
gruel and allowing the tugboat to escape
the fight as it made its way back to the
harbor every boat it passed attempted to
toss bodies onto the tugboat covering it
in fresh blood slowly but surely the
damage to the tugboat began to repair
itself once the boat had regained its
strength it set its sights on a
previously untouched cargo ship and
observing uiu officer determined that
the boat was somehow attempting to
convert the cargo ship to transform it
into another one of its fleshy allies
but before the transformation could take
place a cargo crate broke open spilling
over 1 000 hardtack crackers suddenly
the tugboat stopped everything that it
was doing it took one tendril and began
to count each individual cracker that
had Spilled Out while the tugboat was
distracted with its task a citizen
offered the uiu use of their rare Metals
Cannonball collection in the fight to
apprehend the aggressive boat one
particular Cannonball made from electrum
was able to puncture the whole of one of
the infected ships rendering it
motionless they were elated to have
found a weapon that worked against these
boats while the tugboat continued to
count the remaining townspeople gathered
all of the electrum they could find and
began to fight back against the boats
One By One The Boat sank and all the
while the tugboat continued to count in
the meantime uiu officers managed to
free the gruel from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the gruel had a score
to settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the girl Barrel towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the
girl then threw the tugboat out of the
water and continued The Savage beating
before preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat kareemed through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the Isle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the gruel and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of
scp-6426 6. due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat
scp-6426 is a ketter-class Sapient
hostile entity that in an inactive State
Bears the appearance of a harbor Tugboat
in a constant state of rust and
degradation any blood or organs
containing blood that come into contact
with the boat will be absorbed through
the metal causing the degradation to
visibly improve as a result the most
effective blood appears to come from
humans cetaceans and a few specific
species of solutions The Entity does not
only use the absorbed blood to improve
its appearance but is also capable of
using it to create organic additions to
its body including the vein-like
tendrils spotted in the three Portlands
Cognito hazardous eyes attached to
bending eye stalks Harpoon guns and
cannons capable of firing ammunition
made from anomalous species of barnacles
these Barn articles are capable of
reanimating dead tissue on contact and
scp-6426 frequently uses them to create
instances of
scp-6426-c masses of reanimated tissue
that the boat uses to Aid in its attacks
or self-defense
scp-6426 uses its tendrils to grab prey
and drag them towards itself but the
tendrils serve an additional purpose as
well each of the tendrils has a mouth on
the tip similar in structure to that of
the North American medicinal leech when
the tendril has made contact with its
prey the mouth will then bite into the
spinal column of the creature causing
its brain function to cease as its
canines grow long and Hollow hard scales
form on their skin and their muscle mass
and bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by scp-6426 are designated
scp-6426-a these instances are used to
the entity's advantage helping it to
extract blood from victims at a distance
as well as providing an additional line
of defense and offense in the event that
scp-6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use
scp-6426-a to convert the vehicle into
an instance of
scp-6426-b these converted boats are
similar to
scp-6426 and are able to function on
their own however they are unable to
produce their own eye stocks or cannons
unable to create
scp-6426-a instances and do not appear
to be as intelligent as their creator in
the early days of its containment the
exact nature of the anomaly's
intelligence was the subject of debate
amongst the research staff however on
one specific occasion the foundation was
able to establish a line of direct
communication with
scp-6426 and conduct the first and so
far the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that
scp-6426 responded to interview
questions using the voice of one of its
victims Junior researcher sajad
Williamson in spite of his protests was
selected to conduct the interview his
fellow staff members refused to take no
for an answer and as the newest hire the
unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
the self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize Prof for any trouble
I may have caused and I want to point
out I fully support your mission yes our
first line of defense against the
undersea Menace I am more than willing
to punch sharks selections yes right
how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's first
question concerned
scp-6426 apparent intended victim back
in three Portlands Albert is at
scp-6426 responded Albert his first name
is really Albert
well what other relationship is there to
say besides the Hunter and the hunted
Admiral izat is a ruthless Man known for
terrorizing and slaughtering people like
me he was leading a search party of
those barbaric notophiles intending to
gut me like a seal what do you mean
people like you Dr Williamson inquired
free thinkers of course people who are
unafraid to break from the mold to carve
their own path in life instead of
following the predetermined route set by
that ignorant check valve the church is
built upon the foundation of lies no
one's really a petty officer on this
ship we're all just cabin boys stumbling
around in the dark as we followed the
commands of an off-hand cob
if you want real power real Freedom all
you have to do is listen for the call of
the Beast open the porthole and he'll
squeeze you right through
Dr Williamson feeling rather in over his
head attempted to convince one of his
colleagues to take over when he refused
however Dr Williamson continued
could you explicate your activities
within the harbor and how you arrive
there well after I got the boat swans
off my trail I found a cave to hide him
I was forced to hide them yes forced to
hide deep in the cave which turned out
to be a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel
led to some Coastal Community where I
took Refuge licking my wounds in the
safety of the depths as though Zealot
stuck this surface I spent my time
preparing Gathering the strength
necessary to face them once more until I
was ambushed assaulted within my
I fought for my life as I was forced out
into the open and descended upon by a
manner of monsters and freaks of this
orchestrated by that scumbag ESAT I was
beaten within an inch of my life before
I'm not quite sure what happened after
that I believe I was not unconscious
you'll have to Illuminate Me on how I
came to be in your custody at this point
the interview began to Veer in an odd
Direction the boat expressed confusion
about the nature of Williamson's
questions specifically how little they
related to the subject of sharks and
punching them it was at this point that
the site director sought guidance from
the multi-u Department a researcher
there informed Williamson about the
confusion
scp-6426 had mistaken the SCP Foundation
for another organization the shark
punching Center Dr Williamson resumed
the interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and contention
I mean Solutions this verbal misstep
caused scp-6426 to become suspicious
after a moment it pieced together the
truth and began to throw itself against
the wall in a desperate attempt to
escape it was apprehended by security
guards who impaled it with a naval RAM
and returned the watercraft to its
containment cell the exact reason for
its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently
scp-6426 is kept in a 39 meter by 39
meter by 50 meter containment chamber
beneath the chamber there is an
artificial lava tube the tugboat has a
naval Ram through its Hull and engine
holding it in place this Ram is checked
daily for signs of degradation as it is
the primary force keeping the anomaly
immobile if the ram is ever removed or
damaged somehow a Fail-Safe system will
activate releasing 100 hardtack crackers
and two pieces of electrum into the
containment chamber this is intended to
keep the tugboat occupied until the
naval Rod can be replaced if for some
reason the naval Rod fails and the boat
runs out of hardtack to count while
there will be nowhere on water or land
that we can hide now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the HMS
wintershimer and
scp-4217 contained the Bismarck for more